beginning today the southern nevada
health district will start offering
covet 19 vaccines for kids very young
six months to five years old these will
be pfizer shots because right now
moderna is not available for children
here locally the vaccines recently were
cleared for use on these young children
so you might have some questions about
getting your child vaccinated against
coronavirus well astrid martinez got
some answers from a pediatrician
as the first coveted 19 shots go into
the arms of the youngest americans many
parents have questions about the
vaccines covid vaccination can help with
preventing
severe illness hospitalizations and
deaths in this young age group a common
question why get younger children
vaccinated for covid19 if the illness
can be mild for them dr sarah baslet is
a pediatrician at indiana university
health covett infection is now the
leading infectious cause of death in
children under five and it doesn't seem
like a big deal until it's your child
who's really sick another common
question if my child already had covet
19 do they still need to get the vaccine
they are at risk of getting it again and
the vaccine provides even more
protection over time if your child
currently has covid wait until their
symptoms have gone away and then
schedule their covet vaccine some
parents worry younger children may be
more vulnerable to side effects of the
vaccine but studies show they are
typically mild and can include fever
pain at the injection site fatigue and
irritability as for whether the youngest
kids could suffer the rare side effect
of heart inflammation seen in some
adolescents and adults there were no
cases reported throughout all the
vaccine studies and can children get
their coveted vaccines along with other
regularly scheduled vaccines dr boslitz
says yes astrid martinez cbs news new
york now if your child does experience
side effects after getting the vaccine
then you can give them some
acetaminophen or ibuprofen however
doctors say you shouldn't do that
over-the-counter counter pain reliever
before vaccination only afterwards when
there are symptoms if you're interested
in getting your child vaccinated against
coronavirus you can find a full list of
all the vaccine clinics for children and
adults at eightnewsnow.com